buongiorno a tutte e tutti mi chiamo
sufi la gmac è solo una pastora valdese
di solito a questa frase segue una
domanda che cos'è una pastora valdese e
a questa domanda
io ho due validissime risposte la prima
quella più breve hai presente un prete
ecco però da noi possono farlo anche le
donne e da noi possono anche avere una
famiglia
la via lunga invece è un po più
complicata per questo vi chiedo di fare
un pochino più attenzione sarà un
discorso lungo ma sarà intenso nella
chiesa valdese dal 1963
anche le donne possono fare le pastore
non è stato un percorso di accettazione
lineare facile per una piccola chiesa
protestante di minoranza in italia
eppure questo percorso inizia nel 1948
nel primo dopoguerra e non inizia da una
domanda dottrinale non inizia dalla
domanda può una donna amministrare i
sacramenti
può una donna a presiedere un culto fare
i funerali accompagnare i morenti
insegnare cosa dice la bibbia come lo fa
un uomo non inizia con questa domanda da
un punto di vista di cosa dice la
dottrina della chiesa ma inizia dal
bisogno e dal desiderio di valorizzare
le donne le donne che nella chiesa ci
sono le donne
che in una chiesa del sud italia nella
chiesa valdese che si riunisce ad
agrigento iniziano a dire ma noi
vorremmo fare di più per la nostra
chiesa
e così le donne siciliana e che si
riuniscono in un'assemblea iniziano a
discutere della richiesta che anche le
donne possano accedere a un ministero
nella chiesa
e questo non perché i pastori dopo la
guerra fossero pochi non perché ci fosse
una penuria di vocazioni ma perché le
donne nelle chiese c'erano e volevano
essere valorizzate volevano anche avere
un ruolo più da protagoniste
e così questa domanda del pasto rato
femminile diventa un'esigenza di una
intera chiesa e si apre una discussione
che inizia proprio nel 1948 a livello
nazionale
allora la chiesa valdese a livello
nazionale si riunisce una volta all'anno
a torre pellice provincia di torino in
un sinodo che è un'assemblea con i
rappresentanti di tutte le chiese e i
pastori e le pastore
adesso ma nel 1948 erano solo pastori e
la discussione
inizia con una domanda può una donna
avere autorità di parola pubblica
viene fatta una commissione che propone
l'anno dopo nel 49 due documenti un
documento sui ministeri ausiliari
femminili cosa le donne possono fare
nella chiesa tutto tranne che predicare
tranne che parlare in pubblico e quindi
possono fare visita agli ammalati
insegnare ai bambini cosa dice la bibbia
in emergenza possono eventualmente anche
celebrare i sacramenti ma non possono
predicare e poi viene fatto un altro
documento che invece riguarda proprio il
pasto rato femminile e questo documento
si legge tutta la discussione su quale
autorità possa avere una donna di fronte
a un assemblea di uomini e donne a
partire da una parola che c'è nella
bibbia a partire dalla lettera ai galati
in cui l'apostolo paolo al capitolo 3 al
versetto 28 scrive non c'è né maschio né
femmina perché voi tutti siete uno in
cristo gesù
e questo testo viene interpretato come
un testo a favore del pasto rato delle
donne
un testo in cui si dice che essendo
rivestiti di cristo le differenze
cromosomiche le differenze di genere non
hanno rilevanza e quindi anche la storia
del cristianesimo può riscoprirsi una
storia diversa in cui le donne hanno
avuto un ruolo importante e così
nella storia della chiesa scopriamo che
anche nella chiesa antica nella chiesa
delle origini il ministero carismatico
delle donne per esempio delle profetesse
è stato poi tarpato dal ministero
ordinato e gerarchico che troviamo già
nel nuovo testamento nelle lettere
pastorali e poi non è un caso che in
molti movimenti dissidenti nel alto
medioevo e nella prima modernità le
donne hanno un ruolo decisivo
ad esempio nel movimento valdese
medievale da cui la chiesa valdese ha
preso il nome vi erano delle donne che
predicavano a strasburgo e poi vi erano
delle donne accusate di stregoneria
definite valdesi perché si mescolano
questi due dati valdesi l'eresia e la
parola pubblica e la stregoneria quelle
donne valdesi avevano probabilmente una
libertà di parola e di azione pubblica
come nessuno aveva mai concesso loro di
avere e quindi poi la riforma
protestante nel 1500 chiuse con 20 e ha
tolto alla donna la possibilità di avere
un ruolo definito nella chiesa se non
quello di moglie di pastore e di aq di
trici della povertà un ruolo sociale
insomma ma la parola la parola si poteva
spendere soltanto in privato
nel 1950 vengono istituiti dal sinodo i
ministeri ausiliari femminili le
cosiddette assistenti di chiesa le prime
donne entrano nella facoltà valdese di
teologia per studiare in vista di questa
professione e studiano ma su un
programma che lo stesso identico degli
uomini che studiano per fare i pastori e
non è un caso la facoltà infatti la
vedeva più lontano e pensava iniziamo a
farle studiare poi la chiesa forse
cambierà la propria immagine di sé e
quindi accetterà accetterà che anche le
donne possono fare le pastore e quindi
nel 62 soltanto dopo che una commissione
ha redatto un ulteriore documento in cui
dice che il discorso sul pasto lato
femminile ha due problemi il troppo alto
grado di responsabilità dato alle donne
e il riconoscimento sociale
dell'autorità delle donne il primo
viene smentito sottolineando quanto sia
difficile e gravoso il peso del lavoro
pastorale anche perfino per degli uomini
quindi di cosa stiamo a parlare
il secondo argomento sull'autorità
invece più duro e più duro da
smantellare
perché da dove viene l'autorità di
parola di un pastore non certo dalla sua
persona della sua personalità ma da ciò
che fa da ciò che dice e il criterio
ultimo resta per una comunità di fede
protestante la bibbia e quindi se anche
per un pastore non è la persona e la
personalità ad entrare in gioco perché
lo dovrebbe essere per una donna nel 62
finalmente il sinodo vota l'introduzione
nella chiesa valdese del pasto lato
femminile
l'apertura così al pass del pasto rato
alle donne il pasto rato delle donne
viene accolto con uno scarto
piccolissimo di voti
l'asf andiamo per poco nel 1967 vengono
consacrati al ministero pastorale le
prime due donne gianna ciclone carmen
trabia alle mie spalle
dopo 52 anni dalle prime donne pastore
io al momento sono l'ultima donna
pastore consacrata dalla chiesa valdese
questa è la foto della mia consacrazione
del corteo e come potete vedere c'è
un'altra donna che una predicatrice non
pastora non consacrata essere una donna
pastora che predica che visita gli
ammalati fall culto con i più piccoli
con i giovani insegna cosa dice la
bibbia
parla a volte tanto
prega cantà e una cosa bella ed è una
cosa che ho imparato studiando e
frequentando diverse comunità in diverse
parti d'italia per me che sono figlia di
una pastora e quindi potrei dire una
pastora di seconda generazione biologica
non è strano sapere che le pastore
devono sempre guardarsi alle spalle
hanno vissuto e vivono un percorso di
accettazione del loro ruolo nella chiesa
perché si pensava che erano troppo
emotive troppo impegnate con le loro
famiglie con l'accudimento della casa a
crescere i loro figli e troppo
disabituate al potere
eppure non so se posso dire che la mia
chiesa oggi sappia accogliere il fatto
che non è importante il dato biologico e
storico che ci rende donne non uomini
alla guida della comunità è fondamentale
non è solo importante non resta solo
rilevante quello che c'è scritto nella
lettera ai galati che è stato
interpretato anche come un totale
annullamento per cui io sono esattamente
identica al mio collega maschio
no è fondamentale il fatto che per
quanto non sia dirimente per quello che
io faccio il fatto che io sono una donna
lo è nel come io faccio le cose nel come
io parlo essere una donna pastore per me
dal mio punto di vista non è diverso da
essere un uomo pastore però lo è per le
persone che incontro per le persone che
mi incontrano
è una differenza significativa non certo
perché io ho le tette la voce più
squillante
ma perché io propongo e offre un modello
di vita diverso la mia autorità mette in
crisi un sistema ben conservato quello
patriarcale in cui un uomo può essere
come gli pare
una donna lo può essere solo se un uomo
glielo permette la religione e le chiese
che sono sempre dei luoghi conservatori
e conservatrici quando addirittura non
sono giustificazione dell'ordine
costituito permetto e invece di esser
così permettono un allegro caos creativo
e un po confusionario non solo al loro
interno ma anche al di fuori della rete
in cui sono mettono in discussione
tante cose diventano luoghi minacciosi
io sono una donna pastore con due tette
una voce lievemente squillante e un
cervello pensante e perché io potessi
dirvi questo con una discreta
disinvoltura
ho dovuto fare un percorso sapendo che a
coprirmi le spalle ci sono tantissime
donne che hanno occupato posizioni di
potere nello spazio pubblico donne che
mi hanno preceduta donne che non ho
incontrato e poi ci sono le mie colleghe
e le donne che nelle chiese non si sono
mai rassegnata al silenzio non solo
nella chiesa valdese le donne che non
hanno desistito di fronte ai dettami
della religione che hanno imposto loro
costumi che loro non volevano indossare
quest'ultima foto
ri tra i membri della tavola valdese
organismo esecutivo della chiesa valdese
che viene eletto ogni anno alla fine del
sinodo si tratta di una tavola a
maggioranza femminile e forse una
notizia che fa clamore direi proprio di
no
eppure in un paese come il nostro dove
la presidente della camera boldrini
ricevette nel latte di insulti sessisti
perché donna un organo decisionale di
una piccola chiesa protestante a
maggioranza femminile da un indizio
forte di chi vogliamo essere in questo
paese
per questo paese ci sono chiese che non
hanno paura di dare responsabilità
potere autorità e parola pubblica alle
donne e sono felice di essere parte di
questa chiesa
grazie
[Applauso]